Blake, what's up?
>> Hey, Sam. How are you?
>> Good, man. I You reached out to me on
that Facebook page was started by a
group of Christians. My honor, but they
disappeared. So, it's good I checked.
So, I got your message.
>> Thank God you did.
>> Talk to us. What's your background? So,
people don't know.
>> So, uh yeah. No, look, I I come from a
modest Jewish background. Um mother
raised me as a single mother, not very
religious. Yeah, God bless her for sure.
She definitely did the best she can for
us. Um, father wasn't so much part of my
life. We were definitely speaking, but
he wasn't so apparent as a father should
be.
>> Um, now I definitely believed in my
Jewish faith growing up. As I got older,
I steered very far away from it. Not
because I don't believe in God, just
more so I I didn't understand it. Um,
>> yeah.
>> Now I'm married to an Italian. She was
Catholic when we first got married. she
converted to Christianity.
Um, and you know, just to fast forward
into things, up until about four weeks
ago, five weeks ago, I didn't really
have much connection. And I've just been
re reading and researching and reading
and trying to understand. And I'll just
tell you straightforwardly, my heart is
definitely lean definitely leaning
towards Christ as being that person that
was given to us um to to lead us and to
show us the right examples of how to
live and you know how to how to achieve
righteousness, right?
>> So I don't really need a lot of
convincing Sam. It's not really why I'm
I wanted to speak with you. It's more so
>> just just to kind of uh understand.
Um, now I don't know if it's converted
to Christianity as Lazarus just wrote.
I'm not really
>> We have some folks that get trigger
happy and get excited. They don't
understand. You're learning about
Christianity. It's a process for you.
So, oh, Catholic Christianity. They they
make a big deal when not taking into
consideration your background and
context that you're coming out of a
Jewish background and you don't know
about the distinction and differences
and some of the bad blood level against
Catholicism. So they're trigger happy.
You see? So they don't take that in
consideration. Right.
>> Well, I apologize if I triggered
anybody. I am I I am a little bit
ignorant to the knowledge and I'm trying
to learn. So I apologize in advance if I
trigger anybody. No, I understand your
background, but my my brothers and
sisters who are trigger-happy, who are
very sensitive because Catholics always
get bashed and demonized, you know, say,
"Hey, yeah, you know, are you a Catholic
or a Christian?" As if Catholics are not
Christians, but they're not listening.
Well, they're not listening saying,
"Wait, this man grew up in a Jewish
home, single mother like I did. Father
wasn't around, like my father wasn't
around. You don't know much about the
differences. All you are just simply
repeating what you hear." So they're not
being patient. Say it's okay. We're
we're a work in progress, my brother.
>> We'll get there.
>> Yeah.
>> So I I guess like one of the main
questions that I have, Sam.
>> Yes.
>> And I I I'm like begging for the answer,
and hopefully someday I I'll get the
answer
>> is as a Jewish person, why do we just
stop at the Old Testament? Why why do we
not like believe that Jesus was
resurrected and that he's the Messiah
with all this proof and evidence leading
to that?
>> Well, remember don't generalize all Jews
because the first believers were Jews,
right? I mean, if you look at the New
Testament itself, every book of the New
Testament is written by a Jew except
Luke and Acts. It's written by a Greek.
The first believers were Jews. The
apostles were Jews.
And even to this day, even to this day,
there are because there's not too many
Jews worldwide. I think the number is
what about 18 million
>> about that. Yeah.
>> You have
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
Jews that do believe in Christianity,
that do believe in the New Testament. In
fact, there are ministries like one for
Israel. Let me show you this.
And I'm going to show you some. So
historically there's always been Jews
who believed in Jesus and always been
Jews who didn't believe in Jesus. And
even today you have Jews that don't
believe in anything. They're atheists.
See people think when you you're a Jew
that means you're religious. No. There
are a lot of secular Jews. There's even
Jews who are Buddhists who are into the
new age.
>> Okay?
>> Right? I mean don't take my word for it.
Do a search. You'll see Jews who are
agnostic, Jews who are atheist. that
means they're not religious or Jews who
are Buddhists or Jews who are into the
new age. But let me get the uh websites
for you. So I'll send them to you. So
this is one for Israel. This is an
ministry
started initially, if I remember
correctly, by Israeli Jews. And their
entire focus is on showing the Jews from
the Hebrew scriptures Jesus is the
Messiah. the New Testament is the
fulfillment of the Old Covenant and
answering all the objections by the
rabbis. And here these two are Jews.
One, this man here with the Hadi, he's
an Israeli Jew. His name is Golan. I met
him actually. I met both of them at a
conference. So, let me send you this.
And then not only that, you have Jews
who are Catholics.
There's even a society of Jewish
Catholics. So, I'm going to show you
that as well, but let me just get to the
site. Now, I'm going to talk about some
of the differences because why did the
Catholics here get a little triggered
when they said Catholic to Christian?
Because the Catholic Church is
constantly getting bashed, demonized,
alienated by evangelicals who think the
Catholic Church is corrupt. It's pagan.
The Pope is the Antichrist.
And so, they don't consider Catholic
Christians. So when they hear someone
saying, "Oh, are you Catholic or
Christian or a Catholic became
Christian," that hurts their feelings
because the Catholic Church has been
there long before Protestantism, long
before evangelicalism. To say then, are
you a Catholic or a Christian is an
insult. If you're a Catholic, what are
you, a Buddhist? Of course, you're a
Christian. But nonetheless, let me show
you the Society of Hebrew
Jewish Catholics. It's on my Facebook
page. Let me find it for you. Here
it is right here. Uh, Hebrews
Association of Hebrew Catholics.
They should have a website. This is it.
He Association of Hebrew Catholics.
These are all Jews who became Catholic.
So, I'm sending you links in the private
chat. If you see it's in the private
chat.
>> I see it. I see it. So these are not
only believers in Jesus Christ, but they
became Catholic because they see the
Catholic church is a continuity of
temple worship. The way the temple was
set up in the Hebrew scriptures, the
priesthood, the altar, the sacrifices
>> that is all found in ancient churches.
Now let me explain what I mean by
ancient churches. The oldest churches
that go back to the apostles happen to
be the Catholic Church, Eastern Orthodox
Church,
Oriental Orthodox Church, Assyrian
Church. These are ancient churches that
have been around long before the
Protestant Reformation. Evangelicals
have only been around for about 100
years and they come out of the
Protestant Reformation, which started in
the 1500s. If you look at these ancient
churches, if you go to a Catholic
church, even an Orthodox church, you're
going to see an altar, you're going to
see priestly garb,
you're going to see incense, and then
you're going to see them giving up the
cup and the bread, which is the
Eucharist, which becomes the body and
blood of Christ. All of which is
anchored in Old Testament temple
worship. In the temple, you had an
altar. You had priests and priestly
garbs offering up sacrifices including
incense. So you see that the fulfillment
of second what they call second temple
Judaism because there was a first temple
destroyed then there was a second temple
and then it was destroyed after Christ.
The way they worship a temple and altar
priests priestly garbs and stuff such as
incense is all found in these churches
not in evangelicalism. Evangel
evangelicalism lost its connection with
the ancient church and its connection to
the Old Testament temple worship. Okay.
So there are a lot of Jews or
evangelicals,
but those who really study church
history and Old Testament worship end up
realizing that the form of worship found
in the Old Testament is fulfilled,
realized, consummated, perfected in the
way these ancient churches worship such
as the Catholic Church, not in
evangelical churches where you go up
there and you have almost like a concert
going on. that did not exist in the Old
Testament temple worship. You didn't
have a concert. You didn't have guys up
there and you know just singing songs
like they're in a concert. You had
priests, priestly garments, an altar.
You had incense. You had candle being
lit, sacrifices, all of which carries
over into the lurggical worship of
Catholics and Orthodox. So this is why
you have this website showing you the
continuity between temple worship as
outlined in the Old Testament and the
lurggical worship of the Catholic Church
and why these Jews ended up embracing
Catholicism.
So I gave you the links right there. I I
don't know if they have a YouTube
channel. I I don't know if it's listed.
Let me see.
>> I'll do some research on that. That's
>> Yeah, right there. So when you say why
don't why didn't they accept hundreds of
thousands accepted in fact they accepted
at time of Christ. In fact
Jesus's first followers were all Jews.
They were not Gentiles.
So it's not accurate to say why did they
not accept. Just like at the time of
Jesus not all Jews believe the same
things. Even to this day not all Jews
believe the same things. Even in
religious Judaism, you have
ultraorththodox Jews, you have Orthodox
Jews, you have reformed Jews, you have
conservative Jews. They're all over the
map. You even have a group of Jews that
reject the oral law, the Talmud, and the
the way they pronounce the name. I'm
going to put on the screen. I have a
hard time pronouncing this. I have a
lisp. So, Kite Jews, Kareeite Jews, they
still exist. One of them is Nahhema
Gordon. They reject the oral law, the
tomud all together and they only go with
the old testament. They don't accept the
tomud. So even Judaism comes in a
variety of flavors.
Moreover, if we go back to the time of
Christ and this is all historical facts
that you can discover just on the
internet, you don't even need to go to
library and look up encyclopedias.
You had the Sadducees at the time of
Christ, the Pharisees at the time of
Christ, and the Essins.
three prominent groups. Now, the Essenes
are believed to be the group that
actually left the temple worship, lived
in the desert, the Dead Sea, and they're
believed to be the ones that actually
produced what we call the Dead Sea
Scrolls. The Dead Sea Scrolls were
discovered 1947 where they found scrolls
in Hebrew as well as in Aramaic
in
was it jars hidden in caves that are
dated before and during the time of
Christ. In fact, in the Dead Sea
Scrolls, we found the oldest copies of
Old Testament books in Hebrew. For
example, we found an Isaiah scroll, we
found Deuteronomy. Some scrolls
were very fragmentaryary
because of wear and tear. Some scrolls
were more complete. We have a complete
Isaiah scroll written about 100 years
before Christ. And it shows you the
meticulous accuracy of how the Old
Testament is preserved. But the reason I
mention that is
these scrolls are believed to have been
written by the Essins. When you look at
them, they didn't all believe the same
thing. For example, the Sadducees did
not accept
anything beyond the five books of Moses.
Even to this day, you have a group
called the Samaritans. They're actually
the Jews that mix in with the nations.
If you read the Old Testament, you'll
know that the Assyrians,
ironically, my ancestors, Assyrian
Empire, the Assyrians were allowed to
come and attack what's called
the northern kingdom. Let me give you a
little history about your ancestors,
Saul. In the Old Testament when Solomon
sinned against God and dishonored God,
God said the punishment will be I'm
going to divide Israel into two peoples,
two kingdoms, southern kingdom, northern
kingdom. The southern kingdom Judah,
capital of Jerusalem, God said that
kingdom will remain
in the line of David. I'll give it to
his heirs. The northern kingdom,
Samaria,
became the capital of Israel. So you had
Judah and Israel. They were one, but
they divided. The northern kingdom, the
kingdom of Israel.
Nine and a half tribes
lived in Israel and were part of the
northern kingdom. Two and a half tribes
were part of the southern kingdom,
Judah, with Jerusalem as the capital.
The kings of the southern kingdom were
the sons of David. The kings of Israel
were renegades.
Renegades. Are you with me there?
>> Yeah, I'm here. I'm listening.
>> So, in the northern kingdom, God was fed
up and disgusted with their paganism and
idolatry. So, he sent the king of
Assyria. You're going to find this in
second Kings. This is in the Hebrew
scripture. Second Kings, you read
chapter 17. He stirred up the Assyrians
to attack the northern kingdom and
send them into exile,
depopulated the area, moved them out of
the land and then resettled the land by
pagan nations, five nations. Now what
happened is those five nations mixed in
with those Israelites and they created a
new breed called the Samaritans.
Now why is that important? Samaritans
still exist till this day. They have
Jewish blood, but they were
what we call
half breeds to use a derogatory term.
I'm not trying to be disrespectful
because the Jews looked down upon them
and hated them because of that because
they were not a pure Jewish race. They
mixed in with the nations creating the
Samaritans which means they do have
Jewish blood. They are descendants of
the Israelites, but they also have the
blood of the nations running in their
veins. They only follow the five books
of Moses. They have what's called the
Samaritan Pentitude. Remember, they're
Israelites. So, they follow the law of
Moses, but when they broke off and then
the 10 tribes, nine and a half to be
exact, mixed in with the pagans,
creating a new race, Samaritans, they
kept the law of Moses. They kept the
Torah, but that's all they have.
Samaritan Pentitude. They don't have the
rest of the books. Sadducees only
accepted five books. Pharisees accepted
a larger cannon as the Dsing. So, what
I'm trying to get at is
Jewish faith has never been monolithic.
There has never been one expression of
Judaism. Even at the time of Christ, you
had the Samaritans, you had the Samar
the Sadducees, you had the Essenes, you
had the Pharisees. Even till this day
you have ultra orthodox, you have
orthodox, you have conservative, you
have reformed and then you have those
Jews who follow Jesus. And even among
them, you have some Jews who are
evangelicals, some Jews who are
Catholics. There's even an Orthodox
Jewish priest
who became Eastern Orthodox. When I say
Orthodox Jewish priest, obviously
Orthodox meaning he's a Jewish convert
to the Eastern Orthodox Church and he's
an Orthodox priest of the Eastern
Orthodox Church. I believe his name is
Brother Nathaniel. Let me find him for
you.
So why? My answer would be who told you
they didn't. But if you expect all of
them to believe, that's not possible.
The Jews have never always agreed and
believe the same things. Even to this
day, right, you have those Jews who
decry Netanyahu. You have Orthodox Jews
who say that Israel is not of God.
They've never been in agreement, never
been monolithic, right?
>> Yes. That's what my mother was actually
saying.
>> I had a I I had a long talk with her
this morning regarding that as well. But
you know what? I'm going to save that
question for after
>> anytime you want to. Here you go. Here
is brother Nathaniel. Why I left
Judaism? He became an Eastern Orthodox
priest. There he is. Let me show it to
you.
This is him. He's Jewish. Why I love
Judaism. I'm going to send it to you.
It's in private chat right there. Yeah.
Feel free to ask me whatever. Even if
what your mother brings up, don't worry.
I'm not in a rush. So, I just sent that
to you in private chat.
So, there he is. So, Jews are all over
the place just like Christians are. You
have Catholics, you have Eastern
Orthodox, you have oriental Orthodox,
you have Syrian Church of East. In
Protestantism, you have Lutheran, you
have Anglicans, you have Church of
Christ, you have Baptists, and even
Baptists, you have independent. When you
get two Jews, you get 20,000 opinions,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> That's how it works.